皆が竹と申した僕ありますでしょ子供のコップならためにやったと思うんですけどもた
けどンっていうのは基本的になかったけ
のコンボなんですよこうやってやって吠えたら遊んでっていうのがあったけどもなん
ですけどもうそれがちょっとオサレな音感と言いましたこちら
パッと見ちゃんと炊けたことは言い難いんですけどもう一度やっとり方考えたけどもん
なんですよ深いコプター2みたいですか
大黒てはロケットのように空高く飛びくるくまみながら降りていきます飛ばし傘がなん
かこういう完全米でなんとかってこれにこうやってバーンって飛んだらぼ結婚のように
飛んできというやつでございます
やりますはぁ
まあもうこういうパターンが一番俺が嫌な奴からすごいなんか
[音楽]
難波品はね高く飛べば僕もテンションが上がるんだよ
とってほしいという一瞬で釣っ思ってるちゃって不安なんですねこれで超えれば
飛んで行くと結構乗鞍これも期待ができますねどこでフックだしてこのフックをこの5
分にかけて困ってるんやっていけばシャル子見つけてこうやって伸ばして手を離すと上
に飛んでくっていうね
はいというわけで外に行きました兄の中では飛ばせなかったのでちょっと外でこれを
飛ばしてみようと思います
[音楽]
ッポン
ああああああ
ん
[音楽]
普通の竹とんぼであんなに飛ぶこともないと思うこれでも十分すごいんですけどもう
ちょっと
[音楽]
としたいこちらのヘッド花火でございます手を使う時よりパチンコ使った方が飛ぶと
いうことが分かりましたこのたけど見てわかるとおり軽量化されてるんですよすごい
軽いからパチンコでバーって飛ばしてもすごいとるってことがだったんでこの軽量化さ
れた武智にロケット花火をつけるともっと飛ぶんじゃないかという事で今回たけどまで
ロケット花火をつけてぶっ放してみようと思いますパッチングて結構豚なんで
ロケット花火をつけてどこまで行けるかが今回の見所だったんですよでないか
作っていくよまず用意するものロケット花火助けたことが右手という感じでロケット
花火をつけて知ってなってバーって飛んでいくイメージです
紙テープで作りますほとんで都区部とこまで飛んだら超えておりできますこれ
飛ばすみっかぁ
[音楽]
向きません
th
火力が足りないんで月3つ付けたやってみましょう多すぎてもタイミングが合わないの
で多分3つくらいがちょうどいい量だと思います
労働の増強ちょっくらプロで言っていますはい次はもう3発まとめているております
スライド
[音楽]
me
dea
ana あああっ
ん
[音楽]
っぽい
ムード
飛雄馬位